good Marty gamers today we're playing
for the first time ever an adventure map
this one is called herobrine's mansion
your little kids thought I couldn't beat
up herobrine
you're a bunch of dumb balls okay
forever alone oh wow so cringe Norville
recommended you said normal not easy all
right here we go tutorial in room boss
fight tutorial okay all right we got a
when you kill a boss it will drop a
music disc that you need to use excuse
me I'm reading you need to use on their
attack the rate the possibilities okay
fine
how do I kill it then this is too
difficult I can't do this okay I got it
alright put the disc in nice
I got a quest loot epic alright let's
just get going did you read it all no I
definitely didn't read it uh okay here
we go
Bera - oh wow I have steaks and swords
this is supposed to be hard
should I follow the path I probably
should follow that path this is gonna be
so easy
Samantha you in there I will save you
but this this stinky oh my god it's epic
dude that's pretty cool help us
zombies are surrounding all right dead
dead dead dead okay I forgot you have to
keep spamming attack this is how the
old-school Minecraft the versions work
huh
wow this is so cool hey I got a sword
you cannot afford board ah what the
don't ever come at me when I'm singing
Tobuscus in Minecraft how dare you are
they keep are they spawning am i killing
them slower than they spawn mission
youth enchanted one MLG pro alright did
it you're welcome
you're free take the swords in my
storage chests I mean I would have even
if you said yes or no alright there we
go we have swords now cool now we that
we murder this is what my forefathers
did when they pillaged it's nothing
personal
okay you take it too long to kill all
right we got an obstacle I should
probably eat so what you want to do is
you want to come from the forest you're
gonna sneak up on them
hey yeah hey poop ship ship ship ship
ship jumpsuit don't you suck a PP oh
yeah it's okay
why what'd you buy skeleton baby super
quick
[Music]
that's so cool where's your leader take
me to your leader I want to kill
herobrine so I can prove it to my
audience one or two simple all I am the
strongest
it looks like I'm tickling them
seriously finally making it it sounds
did I remove it or something I did okay
she sex I cannot die
I cannot die at the intro please this is
way too difficult stop it
oh you got a snack for me that's so nice
you will have to die regardless you
understand you understand pain and
suffering regardless yep
Oh Oh dead you're all dead she's super
dead
you're more than dead that's nice just I
just I just I just I just I thank you
whew armor armor armor armor armor nice
is this like a secret entrance here I
feel like it is yeah
alright fun something potion I'm healing
cool this all started because I randomly
played Minecraft one time I never think
I would actually owner Annika Lee
playing one of these this is so weird
alright what some kind of magic is
blocking the door we should visit the
Crypt first I don't even know where to
crack this such a big mansion
I find a gamer's oh my god I am so
spooked out oh my god
spiderweb look at this dude alright I'm
not even I'm not even gonna mess you
guys why did I say stop stop everyone
stop double stop stop it stop it I'm
from Sweden you're not you're legally
not allowed to hurt me it's how it works
I've written the law the law is written
the law is written the law says no the
law says no listen to law listen to law
listen to LA are you stuck you dumb ball
I'm going in gamers I'm going in I'm not
even afraid I know most people going
against hero Bryan would be crying
because they've so scared like little
girls
I'm not dying I'm nothing I'm not dying
you know why because I'm best gamer in
the world say it with me gamers oh okay
look he lost track of me embarrassing
he's so embarrassed I'm tickling you to
death and suffering
don't you ever shoot the man again don't
you ever shoot the man that's gay
nothing wrong with it but it is I'm
saying it Oh God this is death the
stache adapt improvise over come gamers
so this is protection 1 this protection
to blast on breaking hey hey alright so
I hit the switch this is actually on a
run a quick one oh my god I solved the
puzzle I am so smart
not only insanely attractive and good at
Minecraft also brain very very very very
very forgot what I was gonna say but
something good ok so I stand here and
that's the summons Oh God
now they got babies I wasn't ready for
oh god Jesus Lord I wasn't ready for
babies I was not ready for baby I need
to get rid of the archer
oh god this is over this is it thanks
for sticking by my channel drink the
juice they keep coming don't hurt you
three dishes don't hurt me sweetie I
have one health I have one health drink
it drink the can you stop you suck so
much I'm going out I'm done I'm done you
guys suck why did I just fight them from
here
this is somebody think oh my god that
was stressful there you're supposed to
be two people when you do this
that's how pro I am that's just how
pro-am didn't even use any health
potions barely took any hits as well
probably took like one hit and most okay
I did it
alright they're gonna come through here
and I'm gonna surprise sweetie surprise
Swedish no one suspect to surprise
Swedish alright so what happens if i
press this it opens the door so it's a
50/50 are you kidding me brain so large
six-pack all right where did that
minecraft babes
that's what I'm doing right I'm saving
minecraft babes right otherwise I don't
see the point
Oh God oh this is bad deadly spiders of
death oh god I can't see anything don't
need to see oh god I definitely need to
see there's no way I'm going to spread
this oh my god I am Alive nom nom nom
nom nom nom nom I am so good
[Music]
so good so good
ah barely took a shot barely took a hit
okay this one there's a lot of damage a
lot of damage we're using this one all
right made it this far I should really
stop oh okay cool
all right we're fully sank diamonds
gamers fully stacked diamonds murdered I
forgot the lyrics overtook oh hey how
are you dead alright stand still this
will only hurt a lot hopefully everybody
gonna do tweet about it how what are you
gonna tweet about it Oh tweet about it
yes that's a diamond sword
that's a for mother flippin diamond
sword but I think it will come with a
cost but I'm willing to make the
sacrifice yes yes give me his stuff yes
diamond sword
yes it doesn't matter okay that looks
terrifying I'm gonna use the potion of
regeneration and I'm gonna say boom
flicky pickies Mickey I'm ready okay I'm
scared we're making the jump this is why
it's a fish I'm going back I'm going
back I'm not going anything I am NOT
going in there are you kidding me what
was they I'm sure it was nothing right
all right let's not go that way then
let's go this way
yeah I like this way this is good way
hey hey oh god oh god please do not make
that sound again
Oh dead end that's fine
- fine as Hussein Sweden that is fine
God another dead end
fine hope
oh god oh god hope oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh yeah
yeah I can smell the exit hope I can
definitely hope smell the exit now sour
cream and onion potato chips got a hit
maysa I played so many indie maps that
uses mazes and it never gets fun hope oh
my god are you serious
did I do it I think I did it okay boss
fight oh I think I'm ready I think I'm
good I'm I'm like I'm good I'm good
let's go
this is eat [ __ ] don't shoot I'm
Swedish don't shoot them Swedish he
listened stupid Jesus Christ I'm forced
to use self-defense mechanism in the
face in the face
Jesus I'm dead no okay I'm back who's
killing me and who I can't see him it's
invisible all the games like oh that's
that's completely is he the boss I think
he's the boss stop stop okay I'm fine
he's crazy I don't like you I hate him I
hate him just got to keep him cornered
oh yeah this works yes sting sting so
dumb hit me
you just got cut corners cut the corners
what are you gonna do shoot me
what are you going to do shoot me shoot
me shoot me shoot me he never dies
Oh Jess Jess easy Oh
then thy single time zero theft gamers
zero this ooh that was hard but I
managed to pull through oh wow so now I
get to go in the mansion are you kidding
me how long is this I don't have any
have any flesh see I left oh I have one
place we should look around for upgrades
and visit the shop there's a shop but
there's shopping what is this it's a
shop
this is a shop right these are the
people I almost killed before isn't it
hey sorry about that before hey guys
guys I'm sorry I apologized all right
I'll give you this deal you make good
deals
you make good deals enjoy it rotten
flesh I will not ask what you do with it
but then joy and joy all right we're
entering herobrine's mansion oh my god
am i nervous
my entire Minecraft credibility lives on
this wash this stink dude this does a
lot of damage
all right we can enter now hey hey hey
hey hey hey oh god there's so many
hey I know pro strats pro strats pro
gamer move into the lava into the moment
you go you burn now you burn now hey
Doyle Jesus oh there's so many babies
they have babies on their side that's
not fair
I don't have babies on my side I said
despite babies what into the llama
suffer my child
alright cool I think I did it we cool
why is he giving up why do they give up
after a while so weird hey stop I told
you to give up I thought I thought we
had a deal can you gather in one epic
okay next room what is this hmm Tate
series serving fish or cool I can melt
my potatoes finely jack will be pleased
nice food area what's cooking tonight
they just want to give me food I get it
I appreciate but stop nope
no no chicken pescetarian thank you
maybe I should say my Harris there's so
many moths to hurt there we go
XP yes okay so I think I saw
super-strong one this is the boss one
where is he there this one is super
strong
they even warned you about it everyone
knows Pixar the week is raising
minecraft I hope this is like
herobrine's child or something so I can
teach him a lesson about kids that they
all need to be exterminated
I know controversial opinion not afraid
to say it that is terrifying what is he
doing is he immune to fire nice I almost
burned everything all right cool oooh
fully stank diamonds bollocks tagged
diamonds you won't they may cry yeah
that's one talking about girl girl
that's what I'm talking about
Tobuscus doing black voice is my
favorite thing okay
where is this here O'Brien guy huh here
O'Brien more like not here Brian am i
right
press button when ready to fight the
mosh mosh what a strange name
teleport blindness what I've been
expecting you okay I'm scared there is
who she says what does this know oh god
this is scary stop teleporting me
improvise adapt overcome stop that stop
that oh god the lack the ten frame race
Oh once then why do it why am i lying
like crazy
Tuesday Wednesday no I can't see you
that's the point
I'm so confused why does he act
you sad bro Oh God I was trying to
comfort you now I will comfort you to
that baby yeah yeah oh yeah
herobrine more like evil swine Oh hate
stop T I'm gonna get this herobrine guy
and I'm gonna have a word with him I'm
gonna say hey you and me the new ksi
versus Logan let's do it let's go
this boss is extremely hard okay listen
how do I activate it does insane oh I
did it okay nice
what oh my god guys I am oh that's kind
of cool
I can't trade mid-battle this is Oh
holding it then I just swore in
Minecraft oh my god guys side sensor
that because I would never swore in my
friend are you kidding me I might
Jesus Christ this is ridiculous
oh my lord
Kahn I wish I was playing co-op not
gonna lie he's in vegetable this is
cheating
[Music]
he still regenerated
that's what I find that's what I find
okay I think this camp keeps summoning
unless I put the disk inside there we go
did it the victory yes
wait what this is Bridget no no bridge
what the bridge Oh God
Oh God hope hope hope no no no are you
kidding me
yeah I thought I could I thought I could
clearly I was wrong oh no way Jose
to be continued what oh my god what's
that say you were part of the hero Brian
[Music]
we're all excited about the new game
that's coming out and I can't wait to
play it it starts with the letter P can
you guess what it is
here the pie pick ceiling of course what
you thought it was Pokemon dumbass you
stinky brainer
you